what the [ __ ] is done the [ __ ] is done
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined by Redman miss good boss
damn near 25 years in the game TV movies
yes music and now he's expanding getting
into the app game console blaze now we
got new wings from the Nugget spot a
little bit smaller wings but some more
sauce so this will be an interesting
episode I'm ready to get it going ready
to get it go
all right so the first one sriracha
that's no big deal
right the hard-knock life tour it's
sacred to a lot of hip-hop fans you know
you DMX jay-z Method Man ja Rule all on
tour together when you look back at that
time what do you take away no I was just
thinking about that tour the other day
that was the biggest and best tour that
ever really went out the tour lasted for
like three months and a half we went to
every major city there was we party in
every major city there was when it got
[ __ ] nuts on that soil you know when
you have a list guys at the top of their
game
does it get competitive with the stage
show tonight tonight when we came out
you know sometimes we'll be performing
and the [ __ ] still be stacking chairs
right there in front of us and [ __ ] like
you know we go to put up with this [ __ ]
but it was still a audience and about
time we did our routine at the end our
routine was to be hooked up to these
course these harness went flying through
the air and flying through the air so
about time we flew through the air the
place was packed [ __ ] was like
okay we know we had line it but we got
to beat these fly [ __ ] so we had
key and Peele on here I say you can pick
up the can tail you've watched the
episode and did you see the impression
that Keegan did I've nothing yeah I seen
it well babies we never helped raise my
peers really good on the mathematics and
everything that's some stupid [ __ ] I
gotta make a phone call it's interesting
to think about rap dad's you know to
think about rappers having every day dad
issues and you're a rap dad yourself
absolutely when you go to like the
ballet classes or you drop your son off
at MMA like do you find that the coaches
the other young dads or dohsa they talk
to you like Reggie or do they think of
you as red man a good [ __ ] question
some of that field that they're heavily
uh educated in the hip-hop game they
know who tang is they they know to call
me Reggie besides red man some people
might show the cockiness and do that
like it Reggie I know you your point and
then there's red man like
hey Redman and you know white people say
Redman and black people they say Redman
is [ __ ] and wiping the Redman
I like that respect to that means that
they know they'd be they reckon little
hot right yeah no one has a kick that
one has an indigent you get hired from
here yeah [ __ ] so for the next one you
have some amazing throwback Thursdays
but throwback Thursdays are always
without context so I'm strong I'm hoping
I can show you some from your Instagram
and you can tell me what the hell's
going on yeah absolutely
first one this one looks like you and a
couple Jersey legends right here you and
Bon Jovi Ryan Bon Jovi and that was us I
guess the feeling of us being in a very
comfortable environment talking to each
other from different points of views of
music and Generosa music you know he
does you know what he does I does where
I do in hip-hop but we still connecting
and vibing and still spreading the
energy that's what that picture tells me
I see the same thing they love Jersey
and we love what we do next one this
looks like a rock and jock game and it's
legendary oh yeah ray Casey that's the
man Snoop you MTV used to have rocket
jocks those are the best where are they
they need to bring those back that's not
what my list are these where are these
events that was a good time in hip-hop
look dr. Dre in a jersey playing
softball with Casey Casey what you and
Joe Joe was humongous with Jodeci back
in them day but they here because they
knew hey MTV rocky jock brought out
positivity it brought out artists to do
something for calls kids can see all of
us together and show that this hip-hop
and R&B community it can't work for them
make them want to be an army artist make
them want to go be a rapper that's just
another picture of a good time and
hip-hop that don't happen no more with
these games is much fun to play in as
they look like a were MTV it was [ __ ]
hilarious
number three this is legendary yo good
man 50mm with his favorite artist want
some real [ __ ] cuz I'm kind of know my
[ __ ] a little bit 50 cent was like one
of the last made ingredients Oh
of our era I would say 50 was the last
of the mohicans that got our DNA and
that was when Eminem was promoted 52
right so I was watching all that in the
making kind of 50 success and I was
right there bottom right there and this
is right when that plane started to get
off the runway that's what hip-hop
started going there you know what that
wasn't as hot as the last one so here's
the thing about hot sauces some of them
are taste good at first and then they
hit you later and some of them just are
like a little bit nastier and a little
bit tougher and have like kind of a barb
okay in a way that other ones don't
so first off okay that see little late
little yeah yeah [ __ ] can't have a red
man at interview without asking you
about how high how high - you once said
2017 we still on track for that you
think you know [ __ ] how high - it was
just it's just full of politics man like
first of all we shot how hot one we was
under budget we spent like what maybe
like 15 to do it maybe that [ __ ] made
over 100 mil you do the math hopefully
we could start shooting there 2017 so
this one's actually our hot sauce it's
the hot ones hot sauce homeboys hot
sauces heat neste sommer it's a collab
that's on my home you have some men oh
yeah they sent me some come on yeah yeah
red man what do you think
thumbs up come down very good that's
good thank you all the best ones I'll
taste it so far puts a little oh there
you go yeah yeah you know you and Method
Man you've been all over the world yes
and to have a buddy in tow like that I
think you can provide a unique
perspective to my next question which
international city would you recommend
for a bachelor party
it either be Bulgaria Croatia cuz the
Croatia beaches Oman the Croatia beaches
is ridiculous and it got [ __ ] out
there women they got women out there all
right stop it yeah just that kind of
just happened for no reason huh Redman
no sips of water yet or any [ __ ]
bad-ass I'll go through this without
know what I'll be the man the [ __ ]
man I don't think you'll be able to do
it but you would be the [ __ ] man you
produced a couple Shack records right
yeah I did I made my cash in the
president's residence records Imran the
next shot was actually don't write like
he was dope now you know not saying that
in a bad way shaggy no you might do but
compared to basketball players Shaq took
that [ __ ] serious and yes he had the
money to pay everybody to be on his
album in the deal beats but he would not
let nobody write that Shaq will go in
and write his own [ __ ] and he was nice
check out a gold album right and he's
got records with big like he's not got
another guy he got a couple of gold
albums shad got gold albums more than
some of these rappers do we always felt
funny about a half-liter nat rapper
right but he broke the grounds on it and
he was from Newark he's from Jersey he
show what it was to be dedicated and
to step out the box like he not only did
wrap this little didn't he was a state
trooper Shack like so when he became a
state trooper that showed me what kind
of man Shack is he like that he like to
set his mind to something and get the
[ __ ] done all right so this next one is
paying 100% people always claimed to
have hilarious stories when they're
under the influence nine out of ten of
those times there are always stupid
stories but you actually have brilliant
ones is it true that you were once
cattle prodded while performing and
didn't even know it mm-hmm
some are early stages in my career I
think around my second album I was
wiling I also held a lot of drugs around
into and out I had took some acid that
night see good as it got on stage and
was rocking I mean rocking and usually
when I took the acid when I know it when
I know it started working I started
getting a little tingly feeling and
start feeling a little chilly little
cold so I started getting that feeling I
was like oh yeah we wasn't earning
pickup and I dropped the show shut the
building down and at the end of the show
I jumped in the audience was just
rocking with the audience yeah I was
just hiding you know yeah and the whole
time I'm sweating up a storm because I'm
just feeling this I'm thinking is that
that the acid I took I was like this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] cuz every time I was
jumping up and down with audience I
would freeze and be like oh yeah and I
just kept doing it I didn't know it I
was like oh [ __ ]
I start filling my heart and [ __ ] my
nose was sweating this [ __ ] early and I
felt it again I was like god damn I told
my cousin why I put on this [ __ ] acid
is kicking my ass and come to find out
this [ __ ] had a cattle prod in the
audience wearing [ __ ] out in
there with it I guess he was hitting
like eight or nine people at one time
and we all connected and we just
[ __ ] he just hit me like red and I'm
just in there getting shocked and I'm
thinking that's the acid so I'm taking
it yeah that's like no big deal I'm not
trying to fall out on the ground be
shaking from a shock I'm like um I got a
man up I got to control my heart get
through this right here I got to get
through this [ __ ] I can't let nobody see
me fall on the ground shaking but it was
at that point I guess I couldn't take it
somebody seen it and somebody pointed
him out look at this [ __ ] with this big
eyes kind of round in there I guess he
was saying I was shocking [ __ ] all
night in that [ __ ] so here was
to shuck my hair right off my goddamn
mustache you cannot [ __ ] without
halfling flames coming out your ass with
this goddamn sauce here so I know you
came up under the tutelage a little bit
of diesel died and he's like one of
those original rap chef guys yes and
there's this big New Jersey debate right
now right whether it's called a Taylor
ham or whether he call it a pork roll
are you aware of this debate i neva hear
what you said just now are you feeling
red
looking at that water
might be a yeah there I go it's no shame
there's no shame what they've got
gasoline in that one
I was almost career-changing when what
sense I don't know it just made me think
about my whole life and I'm not rapping
well how did I am I making money from
rap I'm not making money being up here
like what went wrong in your life that
you ended up on my shelves so this one's
crazy which industry has the slime your
executives Hollywood or the record
industry who is that again loser which
industry has the slimy er executives in
Hollywood or in the music industry what
the [ __ ] is done the [ __ ] is that what
the [ __ ] is that the worst right it's
horrible so bad I don't even have a
taste
no it just tastes like like like a
somebody give you a metal pole that's on
fire and then you just put it in your
mouth for like no reason oh my god there
is some bull [ __ ] damn Oh God all OH
go back to your question I could take
this like a man respect it
Oh [ __ ] uh slimy ER executives you're
in the music industry or the movie
industry I say both in the music
industry you can see it coming all right
a little bit you can see when you about
to get [ __ ] as I will say in the movie
industry they let you get your glory go
on first yeah well we're in the building
then they say your [ __ ] is you just
don't know until yeah you just don't
know it's or so like they'd be like
you're [ __ ]
oh wow I just bought me a house in the
car and stuff like that I'm already
[ __ ] already yeah sure [ __ ] well I
knew I should have took my ass to church
this Sunday
would you mean that I'd like watch do a
little but you gotta be careful cuz the
shield rips I just do just like one
little fresh drop on it
[ __ ] you don't have to if you don't want
to I don't I don't like the pressure
football shape we doing this [ __ ] oh man
we doing this you can't get cocky when
you're that close to the edge they don't
get cocky
oh hi this is Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage be careful so I'm just going to put
the question is not easy to ask me it's
gonna be harder for your answer but I'm
the worst the worst right so I know you
smoked up a lot of crazy characters from
the movies to music to just being a fun
guy that people like to be around who is
the number one smoke buddy in your phone
your number one guy
okay my number one smoke buddy Josh he's
my engineer he appreciates the kosher
marijuana like we can sit down just talk
about mead and how that will roll all
day in the studio a lot working we just
talked about we and we'd be laughing our
ass home
that's good to have someone you can
smoke with that can laugh at dumb [ __ ]
mf2 like but me and meth come on we hung
you got the family we got our families
we'd be moving so we get together when
we want to roll on a tour when we
smoking we be hilarious so the red man
you made it through you cleared the
plate
yes the floor is yours
30 seconds I know you're a busy guy let
the people know what you got going on in
your life okay cool um we want everybody
to tune in the red and meth app is
called blaze now you can find the
hottest dispensary around the country or
on our app you can tell the ratings of
that dispensary the kind of we and the
cutting the owner
everything about that dispensary you can
find about blaze now download it to your
phone right now and you can find me on
IG Redman Gillan rADM ang I ll a G I ll
a red man gila on IG and at the real
redmond on twitter and my website
I cut CNET